[Music]
it's a very tight race for two very
different visions for france the first
round results barely counted and emanuel
macron was on the campaign trail no
coincidence he headed to one of the
country's poorest towns areas that feel
forgotten by the political elite
his rival marine le pen headed to a
rural community south of paris promising
farmers tax relief if they help her to
the elysee palace
the far-right leader has tapped into
discontent across france by focusing on
the cost of living it's helped detoxify
her as a political option
the big question is what will happen to
jean-luc melenchon supporters
twenty-two percent of people voted for
him in this first round and their votes
are now up for grabs
left-wing melanchol has urged his
supporters not to vote for le pen but he
hasn't endorsed macron either
in the past people would have united to
vote against a far-right candidate but
that isn't happening this time and the
numbers are in the margin of error for
marine le pen to win this is trump and
brexit territory for france
with less than two weeks until the
second round many melanchol voters are
still undecided
[Music]
i have to see there is two weeks and i
have to see what they want to say
in politics but actually it's very
tricky situations if you can say
voting trends are proving unpredictable
in this election the far right once
unthinkable for many is appealing to
some voters for the first time
when you think if you add up all the
votes to for the extreme parties 57 of
the french electorate actually voted for
the extremes and then in the middle you
have this centrist island represented by
emmanuel macron who of course
attracts people from the left and from
the right
this election risks having seismic
impact beyond france's borders at a time
when europe is facing its biggest
security threat since world war ii
president le pen could be another
destabilizing factor
sally look with sky news paris